let's turn over to you perrian you have
obviously a lot going on with this sort
of uh
banned this bill that's going through
the new york legislature can you talk to
us about that because that's a very big
deal as it relates yeah new york is
truly failing us new york's still still
failing
the legislature is planning to ban
proof-of-work mining in the state it's
technically they're calling it a
two-year moratorium um but it's
effectively it's a ban uh this bill has
already passed the assembly um and it
will come up for consideration in in the
senate any day now
um our team at the chamber of digital
commerce we have a team of lobbyists on
the ground in albany
they're working full time on this and
now is the time for anyone who cares
about the future of this industry to
make your opposition to this bill
known so i'll tell you our efforts in
the house
were were definitely heard um i'll give
you just some play-by-play on what
happened because it was yeah
it was fascinating
so what's the who's spearheading it why
are they spearheading it like what's the
you know what's the implications of this
bill passing and not potentially not
passing yeah so this bill is being
pushed by
environmentalists the the head sponsor
of the bill
anna kiels she is a um
she
promotes herself on twitter as a climate
activist
and
i
had to pass through committee before i
could go to the assembly for for a vote
and
we had worked really really hard to get
as much opposition to this as possible
they brought it up late at night for
consideration in that committee and they
basically started the session saying hey
surprise
we have changed the composition of the
committee there's now a new member on it
and that new member was someone they had
recruited who was a supporter of the
bill and that was the only way they were
able to get it out of committee
so they were pulling tricks out of their
bags i mean it was politics out of
julia's best in his words
but it really showed that people calling
and voicing their opposition had a huge
impact because they had to go that low
just to get it through and then it
passed through the the full assembly
after that so
is this bill popular
like if it made it to the the floor of
the assembly would it actually pass or
well it passed the assembly so it now
has to pass the senate it has passed
this um and
we have a fighting chance we have a
fighting chance based on our whip count
we think we need to flip about 12
democrats in order for it to fail
so we are focusing efforts on senate
democrats today
so
for anybody who would like to be a part
of us we're calling on literally
everybody around the country even if
you're not located in new york if you
are located in new york contact your
state senator and let them know your
opposition to this bill if you're not in
new york call the senate leadership
and help educate them on why this is bad
um we have a campaign all of the
resources we're posting on our twitter
account it's at digital chamber we have
talking points we have resources so you
can find your senator
and but now now is the fighting chance i
feel like i represent the sort of
collective it curiosity if you will of
the traditional finance community as
someone who's very curious about bitcoin
believes it has a place in your asset
allocation on depending on kind of where
you are in your investment time horizon
um on your investment journey
as that person as the person who doesn't
really understand the full implications
the full scope of maybe the energy like
why why is this bill even exist that's
what i don't understand like who is
actively out there trying to prevent
bitcoin mining is what you know give me
some stats give me some fast give me
some figures what are the issues well
from my position we should not be
passing such a draconian measure into
law if we don't understand it and
clearly
new york does not understand this
because there's a lot of misconceptions
about why they're pushing this through
they're trying to curb energy use
and carbon emissions well bitcoin uses a
negligible amount of energy it's not
going to accomplish
any of those goals
further there's an alternative piece of
legislation that has already passed the
assembly that would uh conduct a task
force
to put forward a study to understand
this better so i mean if logic just
prevailed which of course logic and
reason
don't always politics to prevail in
politics logic does not prevail money
prevails in politics we would first
understand it and then take action
they're doing it completely backwards
it's fair brian do you think this will
have any implications like what's play
this forward like let's say the bill
passes you see copycat bills across the
nation maybe it makes its way to dc is
there a real implication here as it
relates to the bitcoin supplies i think
it's not passed i mean if you look at
the truth the truth is that if you take
all the world's energy the electricity
bitcoin consumes
0.1
of the world's electricity so even if
you turn it off it has like very said it
has no meaningful effect and sixty
percent of the electricity that's used
to buy mine bitcoin comes from green or
renewable energy sources so in the
united states twenty percent of our
energy use electrical use is from green
energy renewable so the bitcoin mining
industry is three times more greener
than the average u.s consumer wow so
it's it's you know this is just it's
it's it's fake information out there
getting people riled up and it's like i
said even if you turn it off it doesn't
make a difference
gotcha gotcha see this is the kind of
see i i thank you for sharing that
because i've not heard those stats all
i've heard and unseen is really greta
thornberg saying that bitcoin is gonna
you know sink the planet right right
like
i just heard from you
if we turned off all bitcoin mining
globally the planet will be underwater
in 20 you know 51 instead of 2050 right
here's the other part of that so
building off what brian's talking about
in terms of bitcoin mining being a huge
user and consumer of renewables the
bitcoin mining industry is one of the
largest investors in sustainable energy
operations
and we believe bitcoin mining has the
opportunity to lead the transition to
green and sustainable power operations
around the country and potentially
around the world
so by just saying anything proof of work
is going to be banned in this state all
of those mines are just going to go
elsewhere there's plenty of more
friendly states like texas that are
opening them with with welcome arms who
are partnered with renewable plants and
helping fund the build out of more
renewable sources around the country so
it will have the complete opposite
effect